as vladimir putin threatens to detonate
nuclear weapons and plunge the planet
into world war iii democrats in congress
are focusing on the truly pressing
issues like outlawing lynchings which
are already illegal
always have been and have not been a
major problem for at least 70 years
you see for much of the 19th and early
20th centuries lynchings were a serious
problem in the united states targeting
mostly black people but other races as
well notably italians who were the
victims of the largest mass lynching in
american history
during the 58 years that made up the
height of lynching in america an
estimated
4467 americans were killed by lynch mobs
according to one academic study for
perspective that is four fewer people
over a 58-year period than were murdered
in just a dozen american cities just
last year
but democrats haven't passed any laws to
stop the historic killing going on right
now
probably because they themselves
unleashed the crime wave during the blm
and antifa riots of 2020.
at the same time that the house voted to
make lynching illegal again to make it
super duper illegal
senate democrats voted to enshrine a
sacred national right to lynch babies in
the womb
fortunately the senate democrats failed
by about 14 votes babies in pro-life
states are safe for now
but then again it's hard to say that any
of us are safe when an autocrat in
russia is threatening to unleash nuclear
holocaust in the world if he is not
allowed to proceed with his invasion of
a sovereign nation an invasion that our
own idiot leaders invited him to
undertake
while those same idiot leaders focus
their firepower on non-existent problems
and american babies what a time to be
alive
for now i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from steve robson
who says in response to michael's
comment about how this is the first
major war in his lifetime between
civilized nations joy behar has now
rescheduled her vacation from rome to
fallujah
that's true who wants to go to venice
when you could go to a civilized city
like aleppo right
because you know they're all so
civilized there's no difference
whatsoever between this war so insist
the liberals it's insane you know where
i want to stay though right here in
america where we've got
grade a
number one the best beef in the world
american beef brought to you
by good ranchers a lot of the meat that
you buy in the supermarket is just crap
and it's mislabeled and they say it's
product of the usa and it's really
imported from some cheap ranch overseas
and then the cartels here just minimally
process it and they say product of usa
don't get that good ranchers goes to
actual american ranches gets really high
quality beef and chicken by the way they
got great steaks they got great
hamburgers they bring them to you the
prices cannot be beat the packaging is
perfect because they package it in
individual helpings so right something
like 40 of the meat in the united states
just gets thrown out doesn't end up
being eaten because you buy the big pack
of it then you'll lead some of it and
the leftovers you can throw it out
you're not gonna have that problem with
good ranchers i love their stuff i'm
very excited today for mardi gras
the good ranchers have shown up and
they're throwing a big barbecue for us
and i get to eat their delicious new
york strip steak and it's going to be a
blast right now you can get a 30
discount on prime steaks and better than
organic chicken today you go to
goodranchers.com
knowles
to save on the quality that you have
been looking for that is
goodranchers.com they take the guesswork
out of the grocery store they source
everything from local farms they ship it
to your door use the code knolls get a
box of 100 american meat 30 in savings
combat inflation
get your delicious meat delivered go to
good ranchers right now before we get
into all the actual pressing problems
that matter right now and not a problem
from 70 years ago
i am always surprised when i look up the
history of lynchings in america
and how few lynchings there were
lynchings very bad we're all
anti-lynching do don't lynching very bad
but
the way that people talk about lynchings
you would think there were millions of
lynchings in america
you would think that there were at least
hundreds of thousands of but there
weren't there were relatively very few
what was it for 4
400
some lynchings
and actually if you look into the
history of lynchings
the the death penalty was
really uh brought to the fore in america
and promoted as a
an antidote to the lynchings because
there were all these extrajudicial
killings that was very very bad and so
politicians who were trying to stop this
and reform the system actually promoted
the death penalty as as a way to
discourage lynch mobs now
there's a kind of irony here that the
house voted to pass this anti-lynching
bill to make lynching illegal again they
were going to make it a federal hate
crime and they they will do that
as opposed to a love crime i hate you
know those love crimes are bad but the
hate crimes they're a lot worse
but the maximum sentence for someone
convicted
of committing a lynching under this
legislation
is 30 years
to me the crazy takeaway here is that
democrats only believe that you should
be punished for 30 years if you lynch
someone
call me old-fashioned call me a little
fire and brimstone i think the
punishment should be much higher i think
if you lynch somebody probably you
should just get killed by the state
right but the democrats have tied
themselves into nazir because the
democrats are anti-death penalty so they
can't
they can't push for the death penalty
even for as a punishment for something
like lynching they say okay we're taking
lynching so seriously we're going to
give you a relatively
brief prison sentence for it for a crime
that's already illegal that hasn't been
an issue in 70 years
not a great use of resources not not a
very logical
prudent sort of government is it no not
at all but then again elections have
consequences we get the gov what was it
h.l menken said that democracy is the
theory that the people deserve
deserve to get what they want and they
deserve to get it good and hard so
kamala harris yesterday she summed it up
very well when she explained what
elections mean
as we all know elections matter
and when folks vote they order what they
want and in this case they got what they
asked for
i went off script a little bit
she is so
singularly unlikable
i have basically nothing else to add to
that clip other than that she's just
so
painfully unlikable joe biden's approval
rating is about negative 15 right now
and hers is lower if if democrats really
believe that kamala harris is their
great hope in 2024 i think they ought to
pack it in now and republicans should
start measuring the drapes
elections
have
an order and i went off script i know
you did darling i know you went off
script now president trump has a
different take on the election and a
different take on ukraine
president trump
as the shelling as the killing as the
horrible atrocities in ukraine continue
he says quote we are praying for the
people of ukraine god bless them all
they are indeed brave as everyone
understands this horrific event would
not have happened if there wasn't a
rigged election and i was president
show me the lie
show me the lie you don't even need to
believe that the election was
stolen
right in the sense of people were
carrying boxes of ballots overnight and
you had nefarious poll workers changing
the numbers not saying that didn't
happen but it didn't it didn't need to
happen
for
the election to have been rigged
you might debate whether or not the
election was stolen you really can't
debate whether or not the election was
rigged the democrats changed all the
rules in the weeks and months before the
election to be more favorable to
democrats they took away
most of the ballot security measures
that even democrats even barack obama in
recent years has talked about the
importance of they took that away
because they were controlling the
elections and they felt that they could
give themselves an advantage and they
did that they turned election day into
election month weeks and months they
turned the the
necessity to show up to vote
into widespread unsolicited mail-in
ballots
that's what you saw in pennsylvania this
was in violation of the state
constitution
as the court just found by the way you
saw all sorts of madness
the counting that went on and on and on
there was
obviously
a rigging and i think trump is right not
not just about the rigging of the
election that was obvious whether it was
stolen or not obviously was rigged but
he's right about ukraine too i do not
believe putin would have invaded ukraine
any more than he already had under
barack obama then he just sort of stayed
there in crimea i don't think he would
have invaded ukraine under trump my
evidence is that he didn't
he invaded georgia under bush he invaded
crimea under biden
he didn't do nothing under trump and
then the minute biden gets into office
or i'm sorry he yeah the first one is
bush second one was obama it's easy to
confuse obama and biden didn't do
nothing under trump and then under joe
biden what does he do he full-on invades
the country and he doesn't seem like
he's going to be pulling out anytime
soon
we talked yesterday about all of the
propaganda that you're seeing in this
war you're seeing a ton of russian
propaganda you're seeing a ton of
western propaganda too ukraine is not
merely a battle between the ukrainians
fighting for their nation and russia
fighting for its greater empire but it's
also a proxy battle in a sort of new
cold war between the west led by america
and nato and the european union and and
russia
new cold war same as the old cold war
and ukraine is that battleground okay
and so you're seeing a lot of western
propaganda about how well the ukrainians
are doing the ghost of kiev is shooting
down half a dozen russian fighter pilots
and the the you know men of snake island
who were all killed but they did so
gloriously and you know zielinski's
there on the front lines wearing his
fatigues and and none of that is exactly
true that's wartime propaganda like you
see in every war but it's giving a
the false impression to the west
uh which is that ukraine is winning this
war ukraine is not winning this war
ukraine is fighting valiantly there's no
question about that
russia is the aggressor party here
there's no question about that
but i think a lot of western liberals in
particular are laboring under the
misapprehension that ukraine is going to
pull it out they're really close to
winning they're not
russia has
so much more power they've got all the
advantage they've got all of the
leverage if you were you don't want to
gamble on the future you kind of hope
that the valiant you you know
western-looking ukrainians can pull it
out but
people are in for a big surprise if they
think that putin is being routed he's
not he's still winning the war and so
then the question is this
the longer this drags on
the more frustrated putin gets that this
isn't going fast enough what is he
willing to do
the man has threatened to use nuclear
weapons
about as bluntly as a world leader can
marco rubio who's on the senate
intelligence committee is vice chairman
of the senate intelligence committee he
said there's something seriously wrong
with putin this is not the same man
we've been dealing with 10 years ago so
then the question becomes
are we all
going to
die when you want to protect your
security not just around the world but
in your home i strongly recommend you
check out ring you know how much i love
the ring video doorbell the amazing
gadget where you can see and speak to
whoever is at your door whether you're
in the home whether you're on the road
whether you're at the office well you
know that ring has an award-winning
alarm system a whole home alarm system
maybe you don't know that you should
familiarize yourself right now i love
the ring alarm ring truly makes me feel
safe not just when i'm on the road and
i've got to make sure that sweet little
elise and cute little baby june are
protected but also when we're all on the
road ring can protect you from freeze
from fire from flood not just the bad
guys but the elements as well they've
got professional monitoring that is a
truly amazing deal when you think of the
old-timey security systems you're going
to be paying a fraction with ring of
what you would be paying for those
outdated systems
go check it out right now rings
winning alarm ring.com slash knowles
canon wles get a great deal on a ring
alarm home security kit today that's
ring.com
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
are we going to die
not even because of some military
operation in eastern europe but because
russia drags the united states or the
european union
nato
sort of tomato tomato into a war it
becomes a world war there's the use of
nuclear weapons how dangerous is this
situation
well rubio
from the senate intelligence committee
says quote i wish i could share more but
for now i think it's pretty obvious to
many that something is off with putin he
has always been a killer but his problem
now is different and significant it
would be a mistake to assume this putin
would react the same way he would have
five years ago
so there are a few options on how to
interpret what rubio is saying rubio is
privy to intelligence that we are not
privy to but also we know that
politicians lie and exaggerate things
and we know that the intelligence
community lies and exaggerates things so
one possibility putin has a serious
illness there have been rumors of this
over the years they haven't seemed to be
true the other is that putin's lost his
marbles he's got some psychological
condition that means he's not a rational
actor the third possibility is this is
western propaganda and we're trying to
undermine putin and make him seem like a
crazy guy
and encourage the world to
all go to war with him and change the
regime in moscow
none of those situations should make us
feel particularly secure especially when
you've got
a former superpower one of the two
superpowers for most of the 20th century
and then they got vanquished in the cold
war and now they're coming back
nuclear power
very
butthurt about losing their empire in
the early 1990s want to get it back
you've now got them
in kiev mired in fighting
trying to reclaim their empire that's a
very dangerous situation especially
because ukraine isn't giving up gotta
hand them credit they are fighting
much more valiantly i think than a lot
of people expected of a small
nation with a corrupt oligarchic
government against its former imperial
overlords so now the way that ukraine is
trying to
turn the tide of this war is they're
trying to join the european union the
president of ukraine
voladimir zelensky has said quote we ask
the european union for ukraine's
immediate accession via a new special
procedure
our goal is to be together with all
europeans and most importantly to be on
an equal footing i'm sure it's fair i'm
sure it's possible
so in the at the height of this
potentially global conflict what ukraine
is saying is europe if you annex us if
you if you take us in to your federation
uh
then the country will be able to survive
now the cost of of ukraine surviving as
an independent country or a
semi-independent country is that the
world is going to be plunged into a war
russia will not stand for ukraine
joining the european union so what does
the eu say in response to this the
president of the eu ursula van der leyn
says
uh maybe
basically her
her answer is we want ukraine to join
but
dot dot dot she says we have a process
with ukraine that is for example
integrating the ukrainian market into a
single market so you want closer
economic ties we have very close
cooperation on the energy grid for
example uh there are many topics we work
very closely together and indeed over
time they belong to us
they are one of us
and we want them in
those are fighting words
those are not words to de-escalate the
situation right now in ukraine even
switzerland switzerland
is the most famously you might say
infamously neutral country in the world
that's why all the sketchy banking rules
are there and people put their money
there even in the hottest wars they
remain neutral that is how switzerland
has survived even switzerland is
throwing its neutrality to the wind and
coming out against russia
they're not admitting that they're doing
that but they are doing that they're
joining on to sanctions against
russia
switzerland we think of switzerland as
maybe the most quintessentially european
country that there is
but switzerland is not in the european
union switzerland is not in nato
switzerland is a neutral
country
and yet
they're signing on to these sanctions
against
russia and it it got me thinking here
what do we want we in the west
we we want everybody to be in the west
right that's what that's what
all of the wars of the 2000s were about
all of the bush wars
were okay these well one it was because
middle eastern terrorists launched a war
on us and then that war was used
right the attacks on september 11th were
used as the justification for saying
okay we can't just let these people live
and let live do whatever they want
because they're going to come to our
shores too so we're going to remake the
whole world in the vein of madisonian
democracy and it's all we're all going
to be the west and we're all going to
have iphones and mcdonald's and we're
all going to get along just fine and it
didn't really work out
didn't work out very well in iraq didn't
work out in syria at all certainly
didn't work out in libya obviously
didn't work out in afghanistan where we
were just routed last year after 20
years mired in that backwater it didn't
totally work
even here this vladimir putin who
obviously wants to expand his empire but
he is using as the pretext for this
where he's saying the problem is nato's
expansion western expansion in the early
1990s at the fall of the soviet union
nato said they weren't going to expand
east they did expand east they expanded
into former warsaw pact former soviet
nations we're not going to allow that
ukraine is right up on our border and
you look at ukraine i suspect most
people can't find ukraine on a map it's
not your fault why would why would
people pay attention to the maps of
eastern europe i suspect joe biden can't
find ukraine on a map because he doesn't
know anything that is his fault he's the
president he should know where it is
but i bet hunter biden can find ukraine
on a map because he had a no-show job at
the at the corrupt oligarchic energy
industry in ukraine
adds even more complication to this
issue but ukraine
is right there between
europe
the eu
and russia
ukraine is a buffer state there's a
really good piece on this in tablet
magazine by lee smith
ukraine historically is a buffer state
and the thing about buffer states is
they've got to play nice with the big
powers on either side when buffer states
play nice with the big powers on either
side generally things are okay
but the minute that buffer states start
to turn to one side or the other
then you see tensions begin to rise and
what you saw in ukraine for
the period before 2013 2014
is that ukraine was tilting pro-russia
so then the west
through the encouragement of protests
through
direct funding of protests and activist
groups the west turned that government
in ukraine a little more pro-western
actually a lot more pro-western actually
so pro-western that they wanted to join
nato and they wanted to join the
european union
all of a sudden russia says we can't
have this we cannot maybe we can
tolerate nato expanding to
poland or hungary or may to some of
those eastern european states but we
can't tolerate them right up on our
border so all of a sudden when you when
even when you think you're going to
solve a problem by having ukraine join
nato what could be the downside of that
this is great all of a sudden now you've
you've gotten russia into the sort of
situation where they feel that it's in
their essential security interest to go
in and you have war this is something
that
very hawkish very serious very well
respected foreign policy thinkers in the
1990s warned nato about they said do not
expand nato eastward george kennedy he's
the author of the long telegram he's the
author of the strategy of containment
the cold war strategy for containing
communist russia he said it's a huge
mistake it's a tragic mistake to expand
nato eastward you are going to squander
the victory of the cold war you're going
to create a new cold war that's what
we're seeing happen
right now this is what is so jarring
here this is all war is awful all war
has involves a ton of suffering and
carnage and terrible actions there's no
question about it but some wars are
scarier than others and i think most
people believe that this war
this war that's going on right now
between former superpower nuclear state
russia and sovereign nation ukraine
is different and scarier than say i
don't know the nagorno-karabakh conflict
or the war between saudi arabia and
yemen for instance right there's
something why well i said this yesterday
and it got me into trouble i said this
is the first major war in my lifetime
between
civilized nations
and all the libs they're still doing it
thousands and thousands of blue check
responses
michael you
racist you idiot you ignoramus what do
you dare you say that this is the first
major war between civilized nations
in your lifetime what's the counter
example
i can't think of one
i didn't think i was making a
particularly provocative conservative
right-wing statement it's just a simple
observation
and actually
it's an observation that is so clear
that it's not even right-wingers
making it
it's
it's left wingers as well there's a
journalist on cbs news
cbs news not the most rock-ribbed
right-wing conservative outlet
journalist on cbs news who made exactly
the same point i did apparently before i
even
made it now
you've got to make sure timing is a very
important thing here especially when you
want to save money on your mortgage
which is why you got to check out
american financing mortgage rates remain
incredibly low will they stay this way
all year probably not which is why you
need to call american financing right
now lock into a low rate and potentially
save yourself up to a thousand dollars a
month that is twelve thousand dollars a
year think of how much that can help
then give american financing a call no
pressure no obligation no upfront or
hidden fees just a simple conversation
around ways you can save some big money
without starting your loan over
choose any term 10 years and over
whatever makes sense for your budget and
your future just do so now before the
rates rise it only takes 10 minutes to
get started you may be able to close in
as fast as 10 days call 800
685
56 96 that number again write it down
get out of pencil unless you're driving
then pull over
800-685-5696 or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls182334
nmls consumer access
tonight is joe biden's first official
state of the union address and the one
thing i guarantee you're not going to
hear is
the truth you're not that's because the
biden presidency is a total disaster
supply chain crisis energy crisis
debacle in afghanistan all self-induced
right now this war in ukraine
much of it frankly probably all of it
due to joe biden's feckless and
embarrassing leadership now of course
biden is never going to say that
but ben shapiro will tonight exactly 15
minutes following joe biden's remarks
before a joint session of congress ben
will offer up his response call it the
real state of the union or call it a
response to the state of the union put
simply ben will destroy joe biden in the
state of the union with facts
and logic join me ben jeremy matt and
drew tonight at 8 15 eastern 7 15
central on the daily wire youtube
channel the real state of the union
response with ben
will be airing as soon as biden's
address ends on the same channel
make sure you tune in we'll be right
back with a lot more
i got in trouble on twitter for making
my comment about how this is the first
major war between civilized nations not
because what i said was false
those tweets don't get you in trouble
generally but because what i said was
true and you're just not allowed to say
it because it offends politically
correct sensibilities i knew this
i have always known this
and now i have been proven right
by a reporter on cbs news who made
exactly the same point this isn't
a place with all due respect um
you know like iraq or afghanistan that
has seen
conflict raging for decades you know
this is a relatively civilized uh
relatively european i have to choose
those words carefully too uh city where
you wouldn't expect that or hope that
it's going to happen
but iraq is the birthplace of
civilization uh yeah uh okay sure
it was a while ago
you know uh recently things haven't been
great
i don't think you honeymooned in baghdad
white liberals trying to
disprove this obvious point that in a
more honest age
everyone would be able to agree about
everyone knows
everyone knows that the point is right
okay we're we're living in an age
where it's it's not even that we need to
persuade people
to believe that that the things we think
are right are right
we're living in an age where even when
people know that certain things are true
they just feel that they're not allowed
to say it i'll give you an example of
this mike anton uh
pointed this out to me the political
writer
mike anton uh we were discussing the
great replacement conspiracy theory you
might have heard about this people go
after tucker carlson for saying the
great replacement conspiracy theory what
is the great replacement conspiracy
theory the great replacement conspiracy
theory is the idea that democrats are
using mass migration to change the
demographics of america in a way that is
more politically advantageous to them
all right this is a terrible conspiracy
theory and if you ever even suggest it
you're a terrible racist and you're
awful and you're evil except
that the democrats have bragged about
this
openly
in print in the new york times there's a
piece by michelle goldberg on this very
point there have been many reports in
the network news on this very very point
for many years
and so i posed this question to mike
anton
and he said the issue here
is not that the democrats and
republicans can't agree on what is
happening on some particular political
strategy
it's that
the democrats do something
they tell us that they do something
and then they tell us that we're not
allowed to say that they told us that
they did something
it's a degree
of of gas
lighting and living in lies and an
enforced living in lies
that is so infuriating and and so
maddening in the real sense it actually
drives you insane
everyone knows that men are not women
right everybody knows that a man cannot
become a woman everyone knows that the
hulking dude on the pen women's swim
team is not a woman he's a dude and
looks like a dude and just obviously is
a dude
but we're not allowed to say that and
we're not allowed to
even suggest or imply that we believe
that so we all know something to be true
we just all have to pretend
in a way there's some comfort there it
means that the world hasn't gone
completely insane we're just liars
we're just dishonest and cowardly
but we haven't gone completely insane
we've been right about a lot of things
the masks for example i think there are
some people
some people who believe
that the masks are really helpful in
stopping the wu flu right there are some
people who really cling to their masks
in a in a sincere way but most people
don't
most people including all of the people
pushing the masks know that the masks
are frivolous dr fauci gets caught time
and time again at the height of the
pandemic at the next height of the
pandemic at the surge they stop the
curve and the spread and this he gets
caught time and time again not wearing
his mask he's in the middle of the
baseball stadium in the ballpark he's
thrown out they're dribbling the first
pitch at the nationals game he's got his
mask on then he goes up to the stands
when he's actually sitting next to
people
not when he's in the middle of an empty
ballpark but when he's actually sitting
next to people not from his household
he's got the mask down and he's talking
and chatting because he doesn't really
care mayor of san francisco doesn't
really care nancy pelosi doesn't really
care joe biden doesn't really don't
believe the mask does anything at all
lyanna woo the medical analyst on cnn
goes on she says it's just a facial
decoration it doesn't really do anything
but
publicly when we know the cameras are on
they've all got to wear it
and they don't believe it does anything
and we don't believe it does anything
and they know that we don't believe it
does anything we know that they don't
believe it does anything but we've all
got to pretend
that's what we've got to do except now
there are diminishing marginal returns
this is an election year democrats are
going to have a really hard time
clinging to power and so i've got great
news we've got such terrible news
generally the horrible the war going on
discord at home but i've got
i've got really good news kovid was
cured kovid's over guys today officially
i think today
kovid
is totally
over
how did it get cured by the state of the
union address the house of
representatives
has decided to drop the mask requirement
just in time
for joe biden's state of the union
address tonight
the capital physicians said just day or
two ago physicians said in an update
that masks are now optional at the
capitol including for this special day
you're seeing
in
cities around the country states around
the country
the dropping of mass requirements
the dropping of vaccine requirements
all around the same time
kovid hasn't really changed
you see it goes up it goes down there
are more cases there are fewer cases
there
deaths have been very very low for a
long time
there's going to be another variant
experts tell us the next variant might
might be pretty bad too but that's not
what changed what changed was
the political calculation democrats
can't keep this up forever and they
realize they're not getting political
returns the symbol of the mask is no
longer helping them and so they get rid
of it because it was a symbol all the
time
why do they need this they need this
because
everything that joe biden has touched
has turned to ash
that's why everything the economy
foreign policy
social relations
trust in government everything has
turned to absolute
dirt
on his watch and so he needs a slight
any kind of win
so what has he got
he's going to nominate a supreme court
justice that might help him we'll get to
that in a second
and
he
is going to remove the masks and say i
beat kovid how did you beat covet
because i said i'd be coveted okay all
right that's enough to do it
what they're desperately trying to do
right now is to avoid this war getting
dragged into this war could you that's
that would just be the cherry on top of
this
rotten sunday of the biden
administration is if he somehow got us
pulled into a war with a nuclear former
superpower and so they're trying
everything they can to avoid it jen saki
was just asked about this suggestion
that has come from
ignorant liberals and adam kinzinger but
i repeat myself the suggestion is for a
no-fly zone over ukraine in a no-fly
zone it sounds really great what is a
no-fly zone means you know you tell all
the warships all the airplanes to to
stand down oh good okay well that sounds
good because right now the airplanes are
shooting people and dropping bombs in
this so if we if we tell them to not fly
anymore then there will be less death
right
great okay no let's get supported no fly
zone but what a no-fly zone actually
means is
that the people imposing the no-fly zone
in this case the united states
are willing to shoot down
enemy fighters in other words that they
are going to declare war
on in this case not some goat herders in
afghanistan
but
a nuclear former superpower so this
would be
not a great idea fortunately cooler
heads are prevailing even at the white
house
gen saki pooh-poohing the idea when it
was brought to her attention
on military is there any way in which
the u.s would support a no-fly zone over
ukraine well here's what's important for
everybody to know about a no-fly zone
what that would require is
implementation by the us military it
would essentially mean the us military
would be shooting down planes russian
planes that is definitely escalatory
that would potentially put us into a
place where we're in a military conflict
with russia that is not something the
president wants to do so that's a no on
that that those are all the reasons why
that's not a good idea
okay so she she doesn't notice she
doesn't definitively say we're not going
to do it we're not going to have a
no-fly zone but she says you know this
would probably not be the best here's
what a no-fly zone is because she's got
to mollify the people on her side the
gung-ho warmongering liberals who
believe all the propaganda coming out of
ukraine and think this war is going to
be a cinch we'll go in they'll all greet
us as liberators putin will turn tail
and that's that not a single american
will be hurt no casualties on our side
democracy saved you know that
flourishing ukrainian democracy that
even though we were complaining about it
as a corrupt oligarchy like five minutes
ago that that'll be saved this is the
fight for the free world right all of
this propaganda which is essential in
wars
but is not actually explaining the facts
on the ground the white house has to say
hey i know we've been pumping this out
to you but
don't believe it so much that we're
actually going to get into a shooting
war with russia
the pentagon was was less interested in
beating around the bush they were asked
the same question they had a simpler
answer
now that we've seen civilian targets
that have been hit is the u.s
considering installing a no-fly zone in
ukrainian airspace no no
simple enough no we're not going to do
it
sorry no so then then the question
becomes
he is look i don't want to sound callous
about this
i don't want to sound i don't want to
sound like joe biden and seem like i'm
holding out the red carpet for putin to
invade this country
and and take it over and try to rebuild
the soviet union
none of us like seeing what's going on
this is horrible the stuff that's going
on in ukraine is horrifying
you're seeing a
generally speaking civilized place being
reduced to rubble horrible atrocities
potential war crimes being committed
against civilians
so is there nothing we can do i mean
that's the question we keep beating our
heads about is there is there nothing
that can be done here is there is there
nothing that putin could do that would
draw us in to the war gensake has asked
a genuinely tricky question
is there a red line
there are reports of illegal cluster
bombs and vacuum bombs being used by the
russians
if that's true what is the next step of
this administration and is there a red
line for how much violence
will be tolerated against civilians in
this
manner that's illegal and
potentially a war crime
it is it would be i don't have any
confirmation of that we have seen the
reports if if that were true it would
potentially be a war crime obviously
there are a range of international fora
that would assess that um so certainly
we would look to that to be a part of
that conversation
this was the most adept answer i've ever
heard jens hockey give because she's
asked two questions and she conflates
them says would there be a red line and
would that be a war crime
if if putin were using cluster bombs
against civilians for instance which
almost certainly he already is and saki
says it would be
notice it would be
not that would be a red line it would be
a war crime against civilians
and therefore there are lots of
international fora to take this too but
she's not going to fall into the same
trap that obama fell into in syria
remember obama
was asked if bashar assad uses chemical
weapons
would that be a red line for you and
syria he said well that would be that'd
be a red line
that would be a red line and then
assad does it he calls obama's bluff and
there was no red line
sasaki doesn't want to draw this is
actually good news
because
what we're looking at right now
is
not just a simple go in beat the
russkies
that's that
zelinski he looks like such a cool guy
let's save zielinski because we like him
because now he's a star in the western
media and
good stuff pack it up two weeks we're
all back home having a party
world wars have have started for less
than we're looking at right now
a random archduke
was killed in serbia
and that launched one of the bloodiest
most heinous wars
in the history of the world
world wars have started for less than
this we have had relative global peace
and order under
a single hegemonic american empire
for about 30 years now
and there have been cracks in that for
20 years now and there have been other
rising powers russia has gotten back on
its feet to some degree china has really
really risen up
and now owns a lot of the united states
by the way not just the politicians like
the biden family but but also a lot of
our resources they own a lot of our debt
they manufacture a lot of our things
we're in a much different world than we
were in in the early 1990s
world peace such as we've had for 30
years is not the norm
okay wars happen there will be no end to
war there will be no anti-history there
will be no end to war
we're in a precarious situation people
need to be cautious and exercise good
judgment and be prudent
some people believe we're already in
another world war fiona hill
who is an expert on russia she served in
a zillion administrations i think she
served in the bush ii administration the
obama administration and the trump
administration
definitely a swamp creature type she's
just a dc kind of think tanky
policy wonky expert she she became very
anti-trump even after working for trump
but she believes that putin would use
nuclear weapons she believes that we are
already in a third world war she says
that
world wars have co very often come out
of previous conflicts so the second
world war was in many ways just a
continuation of the first world war with
a little period of peace in the middle
and that's not
merely with the hindsight of 2020 there
were a lot of astute commentators who
recognized this at the time a lot of
political cartoons after the first world
war
said you know 20 years from now they'd
have a little little cartoon of a baby i
for every there's a very specific
political cartoon i'm referring to i
forget exactly i'll try to dig it up
there's a little cartoon of a baby and
it was
given the peace that ended world war one
they said all right this baby is going
to be fighting in 20 years there's no
way to avoid the war very famous
painting of churchill after world war
one
all the leaders from world war one and
there's churchill looking
looking at the viewer
as if to say we're headed for war again
there's and then world war grows out of
that some people view the cold war as a
continuation of those world wars
some people view fiona hill believes
that the wars of empire that we've been
seeing in afghanistan
in syria are in many ways a continuation
of that and things could get hotter
again so then the question we started
with
we started with a very simple question
today we're talking about lynchings
we're talking about abortion
we're talking about nuclear holocaust
and the question was
are we all going to die
and the answer of course
is yes
yes it is
yes of course we're going to die
today is mardi gras
mardi gras fat tuesday
the significance of mardi gras is not
merely
that i was pestering my wife to lift her
shirt up at the breakfast table she did
not find that very amusing i didn't even
have beads to give her the the
significance of mardi gras on fat
tuesday is that we're headed for ash
wednesday ash wednesday
is the
traditional christian observation that
we're all going to die
you go on ash wednesday catholics still
they go to mass they get ashes put on
their forehead the ash is burnt from
palm sunday and the priest says remember
man that you are dust and unto dust you
shall return it's the memento mori the
recognition that we're all going to die
and the weird thing about ash wednesday
is that
i think it might be the most popular
catholic holiday of the year sorry to
call it a holiday but it's it's probably
the most
most popular catholic liturgical day of
the year people who don't go to mass who
don't go to confession or access the
sacraments people who don't even go to
mass on christmas and easter will often
show up
on ash wednesday why
well in part because it's very
ritualistic and tribalistic right you
actually get the marker on your head you
remember it's very tangible we're
physical beings important we can
remember that but also it's because
people need to be reminded that we're
going to die there's a twitter account
which is the death reminder twitter
account it just tweets out every day
you're going to die we need to remember
that
philosophy has been described as
making sense of death getting ready to
die
life is a practice
for dying
not to sound too morbid about it but it
actually that's a very important thing
we need to remember it puts our whole
life in order there's a famous line that
i love to quote from dr johnson when i
defend the death penalty which is depend
upon it sir when a man knows he's to be
hanged in a fortnight it concentrates
the mind wonderfully
we in the secular liberal decadent west
have have lost sight of
deeper things in life
we think we're just going to live
forever a lot of idiots
very high iq billionaire idiots in
silicon valley and a lot of futurist
types they think we're going to live
forever we're not we're going to plug in
our brain stems we're going to upload
our minds to the clouds and then we're
just going to live forever on this earth
which sounds kind of hellish to me
they've certainly lost the thought of
eternal life
true eternal life through you know
religion and stuff like that that we
that animated our whole civilization
before it collapsed
but they think
this world you know what this world's
about it's about doing what you want
this world it's about getting pleasure
that's what you want you know if it
feels good do it man life's too short
carpe diem seize the day chesterton
pointed out the carpe diem religion the
seize the day religion is not the
religion of happy people it's the
religion of very unhappy people
desperate people who just want a little
more titillation just a little more
sensation before the lights finally go
out and we turn to worm food and take a
dirt nap not very uplifting not a good
way to live but if you recognize you are
going to die there are deeper things in
this life i hope that we're not all
blitzed out in a in a the bright white
flash of
of putin's last stand i hope we're not
wiped out now i don't think we're going
to be wiped out in that
but even if we were if we died tomorrow
next week or in 70 years by the grand
scheme of of time
it's not all that different it's going
to happen
sooner or later
so what are we doing now what are we
really
living for we live in a time where
where help public health has become so
good sanitation medicine has become so
good
that we don't see death a lot
we really do we don't see people die
when when people are about to die we
sort of send them off to you know little
hospices and things so we don't need to
look at it
we don't hold particularly elaborate
funerals or wakes anymore we've got all
this sort of medicine so we don't have
to think about it
very important to think about that sort
of stuff folks
very otherwise you're going to lose
sight of what really
what really matters
in this life the state of the what is
the state of our union you're going to
hear it tonight from joe biden the state
of our union is we're all going to die
maybe
maybe that could actually
teach us something we're heading into a
period that is penitential
a period where
you're supposed to sacrifice certainly
christians are but i would encourage
everybody even if you don't consider
yourself a christian to do that as well
give something up detach yourself from
the things of this world put down the
twitter
this would be very hard for me too put
down all the constant stimulation and
think about the deeper things there was
a question seven years ago why do
perfectly happy londoners go off and
join isis
why are people why do people
are they attracted to these sorts of
things because men do not merely want to
sit around and scroll and
eat food and look at porn and just turn
into couch potatoes until we die of
lethargy no we
mankind needs
struggle we want meaning we want virtue
victor frankel said man search for
meaning is his deepest longing in life
we want a sense of transcendence that's
where wokeness comes from that's where
virtue signaling comes from
we want to push up against something we
want to struggle that what do they say
soft times make
soft times
make bad men bad men make hard times
hard men make good men good men make
soft do you ever hear that expression
these are these cycles we've been living
in a really soft fatty period now we're
heading into a period that is much more
one of struggle much more one of war one
that is going to be a little bit harder
prepare yourself for that and remember
there's something beyond the struggles
and pleasures of this world i'm michael
knowles this michael knowles show see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
prepares for his first official state of
the union address as president as chaos
surrounds him on all sides that's today
on the bench bureau show give it a
listen
you